herr dr weiter der ist schönheitschirurg
in berlin und ist uns jetzt zu gescheit
nicht aus berlin und wir freuen uns ist
uns nicht aus berlin zugeschaltet sein
aus dem urlaub zugeschaltet deswegen
freuen wir uns umso mehr
ja hallo herr doktor wollte stimmt das
denn gibt uns instagram einfach ein
anderes schönheitsbild vor als wir es
bisher in den vergangenen jahrzehnten
vielleicht hatten
ich weiß gar nicht ob schon anders
schönheitsideal vor gibt es gibt aber
eine viel direktere es vor also wenn man
bekommt alles sofort mit und weltweit
und das ist der unterschied zu früher
früher musste man magazin aufschlagen
oder man musste fernsehen oder irgendwas
die bearbeiteten bilder in irgendwelchen
hochglanzmagazin waren früher auch schon
ein schönheitsideal das vorgegeben wurde
ist das für jeden und vor allem sofort
erhältlich und das schon dazu dass sehr
viel mehr sich darauf einlassen und auch
für viele jüngere früher war es halt so
dass das hochglanzmagazin hat halt weil
sich die 30-jährige oder 40 jährige frau
aus vielleicht gelesen und heute bei
insta es halt die 14-jährige und 18
jährige und 25 jährige mehr hätten sie
das auch bei ihren kunden die bei ihnen
in die praxis kommen werden die immer
jünger
zumindest für lippen aufspritzen
beendigung aller größeren bisher nicht
wirklich viel also insgesamt einen trend
zu ein bisschen jünger ja aber nicht so
extrem wie das vielleicht sein könnte
durch istvan wenn wir sagen ein bisschen
jünger wie jung ist denn dann so die
kundschaft die sich die lippen
aufspritzen möchte und die die junge
aufspritzen möchte oder den bibel
vergrößern möchte was ich jetzt sage
also das ist natürlich eine riesen
bandbreite immer schon gewesen von
vielleicht damals anfang 2007 oder
fletcher noch drüber das ist jetzt ein
bisschen runtergegangen das geht eben
tatsächlich würden ich war 18 19 jahren
los wo es vielleicht früher bei 22 23
losgegangen ist
und ist es insgesamt mehr geworden von
den jüngeren das ist sicherlich so ja
wenn er so junge
mädchen oder frauen denn bei ihnen in
die praxis kommen was wollen die denn
und wo sagen sie dann da ist wirklich
schluss dabei nicht mit und zwar aus
moralischen und nicht aus medizinischen
gründen
na ja das geht manchmal auch ineinander
über also medizinische sagen alles was
man machen kann ist ja nicht unbedingt
dann gesundheitsfördernd also unter 18
sowieso nicht das ist mal dass eine
irgendwelche ganz extremen sachen die
ich persönlich dann auch nicht mehr
vertreten kann die will ich einfach
nicht machen so aber das ist gar nicht
so sehr der punkt ist es gar nicht so
dass die meisten kommen und irgendwas
ganz extremes wollen es gab mal
irgendwann einen einen hoch
geschriebenen trend in der presse über
um welche lippen die so dreiecke drin
hatten nur zwei punkte jetzt gerade
angesagt ist vorüber instagram zu uns
rüber weil sowas würde man sonst in
deutschland ja gar nicht mitbekommen
ehrlich gesagt glaube ich es haben auch
nicht so viel in deutschland gemacht
schlussendlich und sind gibt es eine
andere sache
intel gibt so eine angst offensichtlich
der comics aufgespritzt hatte die fifa
linie unten um die ein bisschen stärker
so ein kräftiger drücken zu lassen
früher hat man das auch schon gemacht
mit kindern oder kiefer linien wenn die
wirklich deutlich zurückliegend waren
das ist jetzt etwas was eben manchmal
auch wirklich so angefragt sind nach dem
motto das habe ich gelesen da gibt's
einen der macht das und könnte man das
bei mir nicht auch machen und so was gab
es früher instagram so nicht er sagt er
wollte tausend dank ich sind ja 18 jahre
alt und schon zum beauty doc schon echt
nach hausnummer danke für diese infos
und jetzt butter bei die fische
bezüglich silikon in die lippe wer würde
was machen lassen wertung was machen
lassen
und was bedeutet es überhaupt also ich
meine these ist ja dass man oder womit
ich mir so schwer so ich habe ehrlich
gesagt schon oft überlegt dass ich mal
irgendwas verschönern möchte ich mein
gesicht und ich glaube jeder hat so eine
baustelle und dann habe ich mir gedacht
wo finde ich dann den absprung also
woher ich dann auf an mir zu
perfektionieren also ich werde zum
beispiel beim hautarzt dabei was macht
der mann nach ihrer merkel falte ich
selber wunderbar danke das ist also die
verkaufsstrategie und das in meinem
gesicht leicht merken
dann hat man dann geht es bei der marke
falte los dann geht's zur stirn runzeln
weiter dann ist mir plötzlich meine nase
zu breit und am ende sehe ich aus wie
cathleen gut ins team ein bisschen noch
gekämpft worden
es gibt ja wenige die danach wirklich
besser aussehen und die frage ist
natürlich was macht man mit seiner
lebenszeit ja und die frage ist ja auch
was will man selber auch hinterlassen
was will man von role model sein und
dafür nicht ganz ganz wichtig auch alle
teile der gesellschaft mit zudem ist ist
kein neues phänomen in der bravo früher
waren die übergewichtigen mädchen auch
nur die beste freundin oder diejenige
die die minderwertigkeitskomplexe hatten
und das selbstverständnis das hat sich
jetzt natürlich massiv multipliziert und
wird bedient und da mache ich natürlich
auch sorgen zum beispiel früher also
erst mal butter bei den fischen ich habe
noch nie was an mir machen lassen
ich würde auch in ihrer sammlung machen
lassen nein ich schließe es wirklich für
mich persönlich völlig aus aber wie alt
ich bin 28
aber momentan zum beispiel mit 18 glaube
ich hätte ich mir die brüste machen
lassen wirklich bin mir sicher wenn mit
18 irgendwie jetzt sondern erst mal
seine ansagen sind nach der am 1
die ist schon immer gut wenn frauen so
sehr sehr viel hatten oder viele hatten
und ich fand immer dass ich da irgendwie
der laune der natur nicht genug
mitbekommen habe und eigentlich von
meine beste freundin ist weil sie selber
auch und ich glaube dann um spider mit
18 jemand gesagt er denke kannst du
morgen machen wenn wir beiden sofort hin
hätte es machen lassen heute würde ich
das aber schlimm finden wenn ich es gebe
also heute bin ich völlig mit mir im
reinen und die laune der natur
verzeichnis jetzt auch ist auch ok habe
andere vorteile ich werd nie kurven
haben einfach weil ich so gebaut bin ich
bin dünn gebaut aber ich finde einfach
war's und märz den ich mir trage schaden
oder seine mehrheit das ist als wäre das
nicht persönlich nein arbeiten das erste
paar aber man will immer das haben was
man selber nicht hat und ich wollte
meine ganze jugend einfuhren haben ich
wollte immer die kurvige frauen seien
und dann in der in der achten klasse ist
ein von den jungs als flachland
gehänselt wurde passiert bei uns ganz
ganz vielen frauen in dem halter wenn
sie sehr dünn sind
da wollte ich nichts mehr als in den
club der fraulichen frauen aufgenommen
werden um bei den typen landen zu können
ja also es ist ja nicht so dass gibt
dieses ein idealbild und jetzt gerade
ist es vielleicht mal dünn zu sein ja
aber wenn man mal zurückgeht in der
geschichte zb marion worüber auch mal
das ideal
bilder werden frauen wie ich als
kränklich und aber dass du dann richtig
hinterher ich weiß ja dass nochmal
spielen 80 jahren war es auch er ist
also sehr sportliche typ was wir sagen
weil es was ich schlimm finde ist dass
jede zweite frau in deutschland laut
aktuellen studien sie eine
schönheitsoperation wünschen da finde
ich schon dass man sagen muss ich finde
man hats doch perfektion an anderen
menschen oder ich finde man liebt doch
in perfektion perfekt im menschen sind
doch langweilig wir uns mal ein paar
fotos sagt wir haben ja ein
erfolgreiches model victoria secret
gelaufen und soll er den goldenen
schnitt haben alles sehr synchron
asymmetrisch angst vorher jetzt kann man
natürlich sagen naja das licht ist
anders der kopfhaltung es anders
nichtsdestotrotz der hatte auch schon
hoffnung gesprochen dass sie hier und da
ist ja jetzt topmodel das brutale ist ja
dass sie vielleicht so kein topmodel
geworden erich und zwar nicht weil sie
etwas dafür kann sondern weil wir in so
einer gesellschaft werden die genau das
verlangt ich glaube aber auch dass was
man auch dazusagen muss ist dass familie
hadid auch sonst genug geld da die
komplette karriere dann konnten so dass
hier schieden david hat auch offen
darüber gesprochen hat gesagt ja ich hab
was machen dass mir hätte geahnt da ist
auch den ein paar unterschiede von links
nach rechts
betreiber ist doch links 1000 also ich
fand auch bei bella hadid jetzt also
jetzt immer ganz ehrlich das ist doch ja
ja ja und das ist natürlich deswegen
wirklich besorgniserregend weil es eine
millionen junger mädchen da draußen gibt
die sie ganz ganz ganz toll finden
und ich glaube was war auch die nolan
hat wir müssen auch demnächst leider zum
ende kommen leider leider leider haben
wir noch mal ein spiel ganz kurz
was los werden und zwar ich hatte mich
damals dazu entschieden zu sagen ich
lasse hier und da in meinem gesicht gern
etwas optimieren damit ich mich frischer
fülle damit ich frischer aussähe
der grund weshalb ich das gemacht habe
weil ich finde das viel zu wenig drüber
gesprochen wird das ist ein riesen
tabuthema und das ist so gefährlich weil
wenn wir jetzt allen anderen frauen
vorgaukeln ganz besonders bei meiner
branche nur ich hab nie was machen das
ist es brokkoli und fidschi wasser sie
fragen sich die anderen nämlich was
stimmt denn mit mir nicht und genau da
fängt das problem für mich an was in
meinen augen schön ist oder nicht schön
ist es doch kann doch shirin oder wen
auch immer alle sind völlig booms sein
und das verstehe ich auch aber ich finde
aber man muss wirklich anfang offen zu
sprechen und offen auf zu klären weil
man dann auch vielleicht es schafft die
ganzen scharlatanen die so tun als
könnten sie alles und machen diese 30
euro das will ich so gut also das finde
ich auch wenn man was macht ein bisschen
ich zu sagen das war viel schlaf und
zehn stunden schlaf und yoga ja da sind
ja auch also müssen einfach sagen ich
hab hier ein bisschen da ein bisschen
also werbung für ich habe ganz ehrlich
war
das ist die eine sache selber zu sagen
ich hab was machen lassen ich mache es
auch gerne aber es heißt du befürworte
ist ja eigentlich den
schönheitsoperationen verstand ich
befürworte es dass man offen darüber
spricht ich befürworte es ein tabu zu
brechen um genau das nicht
oder um genau das zu erreichen was ich
vorhin gesagt haben dass man eben nicht
zu irgendeinem hinterhof arzt und und
weil man dann 30 euro spar zeitweise
auch teuer ist sondern dass man wenn das
zum spezialisten geht und das war mir
tatsächlich wirklich ein großes feld
testimonial geworden da und warten also
nicht viel schöner zu lesungen für eine
schöne das weil ich dann in dem zuge
natürlich auch sehr offen darüber reden
konnte und auch sehr viel aufklärung
machen konnte und es gibt für mich
nichts schlimmeres als wenn ich einfach
offensichtlich sehe dass leute über
sowas lügen weil das tut uns eigentlich
gut und zusammen sind wir doch viel
stärker warum bist du jetzt nicht mehr
bin ich jetzt letzte frage ist nur ein
vertrag war aber du willst auch mal
machen ich habe mir darüber keine
gedanken gemacht aber wir gern
[Musik]